I want to pull up this tweet for a
Marjorie Taylor green
she says we need a national divorce we
need to separate by Red States and blue
States and shrink the federal government
everyone I talk to says this from the
sick and disgusting woke culture issues
shoved down our throats to the Democrats
traitorous America last policies we are
done
Stewart says but we get to keep the name
right and then Nicole Pearl Pearl Roth
Pro Roth says cool California can keep
the tech AG livestock Georgia can keep
their infant mortality incarceration
rates and the country's lowest wages
I find it interesting yeah you can see
it it's down here Michael malice I love
this topic by the way he posted the case
for American secession from Observer why
it's time to disunite the United States
Marion Williamson did you just call for
a civil war does she know what happened
the last time a few States said they
wanted to leave it's a funny thing for
Marianne to say because like yes the
Confederates did say hey we're going to
leave and then the the union was like no
you're not and then sent troops down so
uh the funny thing is there are many
people left Sarah Silverman I think she
said this a while ago didn't she said
something about a national divorce
I know she has talked about it I don't
know about Sarah Silverman specifically
but it's definitely something that comes
up University of Virginia did they have
a center for politics they did this poll
last last October and they found that
like 50 of trump supporters are in favor
of a national divorce or secession and
uh 41 of Biden uh supporters are also
like nah that sounds good we'll we'll
split up I mean it's it's a majority
opinion that both political parties seem
to hold which is kind of wild yes Sarah
Silverman did say maybe we should break
up but to divide into like two or three
countries so this is a this is a really
great example of why we probably are
headed towards a national divorce the
fact that Marjorie Taylor green two
years okay actually I think to be fair
was it September September so a year and
a half
after Sarah Silverman calls for this
Marjorie Taylor green calls for it and
now Liberals are angry how dare you say
something that Sarah Silverman said a
year and a half ago actually bipartisan
right it's bipartisan and not only that
marjorie's led to the party to me
we absolutely need a national divorce
which is why it'll never happen all
right because first of all as we just
discussed with the James O'Keefe story
we can't have nice things in the era in
which we live but I think
what we're up against won't let us go
I
you're dealing with Jehovah's Witnesses
that have tanks all right the the the
the the same thing that that has the
Jehovah's you ever have the Jehovah's
Witness comes to your door on a Saturday
and it's always on the best weather
Saturday of the year every time it's
like they plan it always it may just be
that they only go out when it's nice out
that could be it too and and see now I'm
the guy that pushes back because I'm
just that kind of douche and so I will
ask them questions like so let me get
this straight only 144 000 are going to
be saved oh yeah
well I Googled it and there's four
million of you
so maybe I'll need to settle this
argument amongst yourselves before you
bug the dog out of us and just tell me
once well only that money will be saved
and they've already been selected and I
was like so what are we doing
but but it's that level it's Lyndon
laroucheon I'm in an airport Hangar
holding up signs about Margaret Thatcher
20 years after she's dead level of
zealotry that that the spirit of the age
that these these sorts of statists and
who am I talking about these are the
people that put their pronouns in their
bio and before they had that the Ukraine
flag in their bio and before they had
that they had their vax pass or their
their vax card in their bio and before
they had that they had their mask in
their bio let me show how virtuous of a
lemming I am to the spirit of the age to
the state that level of zealotry isn't
going to let you walk away they're here
to fix you
they're here to fix you and if you don't
think you need to be fixed you will be
made to care and the only reason the
tanks aren't rolling yet is because you
all own about 400 million guns if you
didn't the tanks would be rolling
already well they're working on that
part yeah and so they're not going to
let she's right when she says that but
any society that really needs that would
not be able to accomplish it either
because the divisions that exist once
not both sides are not going to agree to
peaceably walk away the when you come to
the brink when you're about to ruin as
much Freedom liberty and prosperity as
this country is about to flush down the
toilet that only happens because the
forces that have pushed us to this Brink
are on some you use the word cult I use
that in my show a lot the level of
cultic zeal that says to hell with all
those things I have to win this argument
no matter what you cannot reason with
that that level of zeal will not let you
walk away let me ask you how many uh
countries have the freedoms guaranteed
that that we have like the Constitution
the Bill of Rights freedom of speech how
many others has enumerated and itemizes
us I would argue none probably I think
it's probably close to none I think
maybe Liberia has something similar
because it was created by Americans or
something like that not that it's really
working out for him to be completely
honest but uh I have to wonder then if
it is a good thing for these bad people
to see the U.S break apart because it
would remove one of the only true free
or close to free as we can get societies
and look this has its problems it's not
completely free they're still uh
tribalism there's all these issues but
man I've been to some of these countries
been to countries where the cops will
just kill you and that's it the world is
not look I'll say watch Yellowstone have
you been have you ever seen that show
I've been watching it recently so I'm
gonna use it as analogies non-stop but
in this show they just kill people
you're in Montana you're in the United
States but you're still in the wild west
and they just kill people right you go
to other countries the whole country is
the Wild West you're in a city watch the
videos out of Brazil you ever see these
Brazilian videos dudes chilling in like
a grocery store and someone walks in
with a gun they start shooting at them
and then it's motorcycles pull up and
jump out and Rob you and then people
start shooting at each other I know we
have those things happen here too but
it's not that bad it's it's we we often
think things are way worse than they are
and some things are worse than other
countries don't get me wrong some
countries are nicer but I'm not going to
sit here and act like Sweden because of
its lower crime rate is better than the
us when the people in Sweden live under
a boot and are scared to speak up and
losing their jobs because their whole
country is woke the United States has a
lot of really awesome things going for
it but we're losing it and if people
don't speak up it's going to become bad
now as it pertains to National divorce
I think that the challenge is you know
someone super chatted that too much
blood and treasure was sacrificed for
this Union and that's an interesting
point
I know Michael malice I know
lucrutkowski they talk about National
divorce and my the issue I have with it
is in the end it benefits those who seek
to subjugate the world because at the
very least it would split the territory
of freedom in half
if the country breaks apart
then we know the blue States Go full
Canada and and then there's even less
freedom in the world it would be the
greatest breeding ground for limited War
the world had ever seen if the US were
to split in half it'd be one side would
be communist Chinese funded and then the
other side would be the remnants of the
United States or so how's that any
different than what we have right now
well bomber planes would be dropping
bombs on Tulsa Oklahoma you know like
annihilated cities that's why I don't
think it can be but this is
what you explained there a second ago in
is why people want it and then why I
think we can't achieve it
we we we're talking we got people want
to Rattle Sabers about with China
what would a war between the U.S and
China ultimately decide the language the
social credit system will all eventually
go to is in that's really what we're
fighting for that's what it is that
would there would be no higher principle
other than do you prefer Mandarin do you
like Chinese hieroglyphics on your
social credit score or do you want it
accessible in English because every
major cultural institution in this
country either is already owned by the
Chinese or aspires to be like them and
so we're already in the dynamic that you
described that that Dynamic exists now
but the end result of seeing it play
itself out would also result in what you
are concerned about we are headed there
there's that's unavoidable unless you
start seeing great Awakenings what where
do we have Liberty in America to begin
with it's not a coincidence you had
Great Awakening spiritual revivals that
then led to Liberty in the country all
right and and that's why John Adams said
constitutions only for a moral and
religious people you can't have limited
government with people they think their
character has no limits upon it they'll
then eventually think I can do whatever
the hell I want and then make you pay
the bill and the freight for it when it
blows up in my face that's what we have
now called the welfare state So
eventually we're going to either see
Revival like we saw at the dawn of the
country or you're going to see the end
of the country and that's the path that
we're on right now this is a point of no
return what does Revival look like in a
modern sense like it is it a return to
patriotism like how would you see
pictures of Revival
[Laughter]
it has to begin with an acknowledgment
of the god that our rights come from do
we believe in God that's that to me when
Chesterton said America is the only
country ever founded on a Creed that's
really what he meant that our rights
come and he was observing this as an
English Theologian a British Theologian
observing you know basically their
offspring and and how it had taken off
after the Revolutionary War period and
that was his observation is that America
took the the notion that rights come
from God the laws of nature and Nature's
God and therefore they're not bestowed
by governments and therefore governments
don't have the ability to take them away
and governments are just as accountable
to that same God as the people that
rights come from now we have civil
rights we don't have individual rights
we have group rights now uh we we don't
have a justice system based on
restitution anymore that's what stuff
like eye for an eye in the Bible means
doesn't literally mean eye for an eye it
means what you have taken from someone
else must be taken from you or you must
restore it there must be restitution we
don't have that now now you're now
you've committed a crime against Society
everything is centralized everything's
collectivist we see this in health care
that's why we had a that's why we had
covid fascism because Obamacare ended
the Last Vestige of the patient provider
relationship left in America men will
pay for Pap smears now you're all on a
community rating now everybody's a unit
now everybody's a file I mean if you if
dude go back and listen to Bob Seger's I
feel like a number from like 40 years
ago that's freaking prophecy on where we
are right now Californication by the Red
Hot Chili Peppers is really about
wokeism that's what that's what
Californication is is the is wokeism are
you saying about that in 2003 or
something what was it just reference 40
years ago the Bob Seger's feel like a
number go look at go Google the lyrics
for that it'll read like prophecy of
21st century America one of the problems
of us all having rights given from God
that we founded the country on it except
for those people those Savages they're
not even human they have no they didn't
even they weren't even human to those
people they killed the Native Americans
and slaughtered them and the black
people were three-fifths of a human uh
in the eyes of God according to the
founders so like yeah we say it's God
given us rights but like obviously the
history shows otherwise we slaughtered
90 of the native population that we
didn't consider him human I mean the
people didn't even consider him human at
the time which is like the most
abhorrent thing in the eyes of God I can
imagine is that humans would consider
another human non like a a dirty animal
non-human and then kill it and say it
has no rights so how do we justify now
here's here's the challenge I think Ian
is that everybody projects and one of
the big mistakes people make when it
comes to any kind of historical Conquest
is the projection of your cultural
values under cultures that no longer
exist or have deeply different values so
I find this interesting in in in in
history the idea that all humans are
sound morally and that we should agree
with all of their ways of life like you
know the Aztec notoriously would
sacrifice people rip their hearts out or
whatever what do they do they put on an
altar and then like cut them open with
obsidian yeah and then and and while
they're alive and things like that so
you got to understand stepping on
mushrooms even even deeply religious I
mean like the the colonial Europeans
were deeply religious and probably very
zealous in terms of their beliefs but
imagine how you would feel as this like
somewhat liberal libertarian type Modern
Man watching a bunch of people drag a
screaming woman upstairs and then Jammer
in the chest with obsidian and cut her
open in front of you you wouldn't be
thinking these are good people you'd be
thinking these these people are animals
oh my oh my God I mean not literal
animals you're saying that in a
derogatory sense like what is wrong with
these people I'm not saying every Native
American population was that way I'm
just saying what happens is young people
today look around at this society that
we've built Through Blood and sacrifice
blood and treasure for all of the death
thought along the way the Civil War
itself how many dead Union Soldiers to
preserve this Union ultimately leading
to the end of the Civil War not that it
was the exact intention of the Civil War
but that was a big component of it and
then they say look at this and say all
societies must have been this way and
the contest conquest of such must have
been wrong and it's like dude like that
group of people was going around
murdering kids and raping women non-stop
yeah we all agree that was a bad thing
and they got conquered thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast I RL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time